ce film est fait pour vous si vous aimez
la neige c'est si vous préférez la pluie
si vous aimez prendre l'avion
si vous préférez le bateau quand tu es
le sommaire est certain si vous ne les
aimez pas ce film est plus épais si vous
aimez l'escaladent m6
l école
voilà pourquoi je suis votre supérieur
les stagiaires si vous aimez les
énarques lois des états laisse place aux
règlements des multinationales ou si
vous préférez les paresseux si vous
aimez la tendresse et si vous méritez
des baffes ses films est fait pour vous
si vous aimez les flingues
vous préférez les papillons si vous
aimez les jolies filles ou que vous
préférez les cobras si vous n'aimez pas
vous faire tripoter
si vous changez d'avis ce film est fait
pour vous avec vimala pons
mathé pascal légitimus
mathieu amalric et jean luc bideau
ici vous êtes en guyane alors même si
vous préférez les livres au pognon blanc
jaune noir orange vert bleu vous êtes
susceptible d mais la loi de la jungle
après la fille du 14 juillet la loi de
la jungle ce prochain film dans ton
intérêt jasko